MARK MIRCHANDANI: Setting up
your Google Cloud Platform
resources correctly can save you
a lot of trouble down the road.
Let's look at how to manage
resources and the resource
hierarchy by adding
new resources,
managing permissions,
and creating labels.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When setting up your resource
hierarchy in the GCP console,
you'll need to be assigned
the right permissions,
such as the organization
administrator and folder
creator roles.
This will ensure that you have
the right permissions when
setting up the initial
structure for your organization.
But don't forget to go
back and review permissions
after you're set up to
ensure only the right people
can update your resources.
The best place to
manage your resources
is on the resource
management page, which you
can find under IAM and Admin.
This page shows all the
resources in an organization
and lets you manage them.
Let's go through an
example of bringing
on a new line of business
to an organization.
We'll start by adding
a folder directly
under the organization called
Department Y. To do this,
we can just click the Create
Folder button and type
in Department Y. A folder can
exist under the organization
or under another folder based
on your organization structure.
For example, we could create
production and development
folders to help organize
your projects further
for each department.
Since Department Y is
a new line of business,
we'll create it at the
organization level.
Just like folders, when
we create a project,
we can choose a single
parent location,
such as our new folder.
Now that we have multiple
lines of business,
our shared
infrastructure project
should probably
have its own folder.
Let's create a new folder
called Shared Infrastructure.
After that, we can move the
project under our new folder
by using the Options menu.
Now our lines of business
and our shared infrastructure
have their own
independent folders.
We can also manage
permissions on the right hand
side for the organization,
folders, and projects.
Since we've just created a
new folder for our shared
infrastructure team, let's make
sure they have project creator
access to this new folder.
We can select the folder
and click Add Member.
Let's add the shared infra group
and choose Project Creator.
Now members of the
shared infra group
can create projects
under this folder.
But it looks like everyone
else in the organization
can as well.
That's because this
permission is being inherited
from the organization.
We can use the toggle to see
which permissions have been
added directly or inherited.
Since permissions are
inherited, folders
are also a good way
to organize projects
that have similar
permissions requirements.
Google recommends a
least privilege approach.
So you should only
grant access to those
who absolutely need it.
Let's go ahead and remove
the permission for everyone
in the org to create projects
by choosing the organization
and removing that permission.
Other best practices include
using groups wherever possible
and to test permission
changes before making
the actual change.
There's a link below
with more tips.
Another way to
organize resources
is by adding labels,
which are key value
pairs that you can filter on.
For example, it may make
sense to label projects
with a component.
We'll select Department
X Prod and apply
a new label called Component
and set it to Dashboard.
Other common uses
for labels include
distinguishing instances owned
by different call centers
or teams.
As we've shown, the
resource management page
is a great place to see what
your organization looks like
and to mange your resources.
Check out the links below
for more information.